when did you start singing together
well we knew we had beautiful faces but
then we thought
what if we also had beautiful voices
and we did
done
they're ready for our run through
those guys got discovered on tick-tock
doing push-ups to the audio of reagan
being shot anyway they seem cool i say
we do a stripped-down version of
momentum four stools one spotlight that
way we backpocket the dance version for
the album and blow minds
well
just one second
hi hi i just got like five more emails
from kara can max do karate on
wednesdays jane's son has peanut
reintroduction on tuesdays john okay
one of my gifts is noticing inefficient
[ __ ]
why don't they email scott i don't know
it's just a bunch of moms i barely know
this chain is sexist mom's assuming
other moms manage their kids schedules
it's 2022. mom's reserved the right to
be terrible thank you
yeah like why does this chick just
automatically reach out to me vag this
is a bias we have to examine as a
society oh my god i'm so bored
do it wednesday works adding scott in
case there's anything else to hash out
this is how change happens here we go
the boys will collab of course i'll wait
till you're ready girl but like
how long though how long does it hard to
my guys are hot huh
you wrecked collab larry they live in my
hype house well technically it's my
mother's house but she's too sick to
leave her room anywho good luck out
there tonight may the best man win well
well it's not a competition and we're
all on the same label yeah of course
it's a competition property records is
brand new
every new fan casts a wide net but they
only push the horse that's gonna put him
on the map
those exact stuff they are trying to
pick property's [ __ ] ignore him mind
games remember when netflix started
right it was all about house of cards
spacey innocent oh
but that same year they also dropped bad
samaritan starring david faustino it
didn't even get a billboard i know
because i had a big part in it as a
picnic freak yeah we both know their
horse will probably be the country kid
with the lisp because inclusion or
whatever it's tonight a horse race
one month
that's the exact same place i make when
i wear adventurous jeans tate is judging
people's reactions well then we
shouldn't leave anything to the
imagination let's do the club version of
momentum
please welcome girls five ever
we got we got we got we got we got we
got we got we got
[Music]
we're contenders
but we can be tender unstoppable this us
ain't toppable
courageous
[Music]
we're driving
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
momentum that's wrong
[Applause]
[Applause]
turn the page momentum time to rage
momentum turn the wheel momentum
stainless steel momentum sign the deal
momentum guess it's real movement
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] i had too much momentum
[Applause]
[Music]
together
[Music]